European Commission President  jean-claude Juncker will deliver his  State of the Union address before  Parliament the last before the 2019  European elections Parliament will host  the next debate in the future of Europe  series this time with the Greek Prime  Minister Alexis tsipras concerns about  the rights of citizens and the  independence of judges is hungry in  breach of EU values Emmy B's will debate  the rule of law in Hungary Prime  Minister Viktor Orban will attend the  session and present his views at the  beginning of the discussion members will  debate and vote on updating EU copyright  rules they want artists and journalists  to get fair pay for their work online  and for the needs of online users to be  met Parliament will discuss establishing  the European solidarity core it will  bring together young volunteers to  contribute to community projects across  Europe  [Music]